hi I'm Dominic and this is the map of
medicine it was a real challenge to get
my head around this subject because it's
a huge area of human knowledge but this
is what I've come up with we'll look at
the areas of medical practice and then
also all of the surrounding supporting
sciences and like all my maps if you
want to get your hands on a physical
poster go to dosmaps.com to buy one
along with our professor astrocat books
which all helps me make more videos like
this but first we'll start with the
principles of Medicine
many medical interventions cause
short-term damage or have harmful side
effects but in order to gain long-term
benefits so medical practitioners follow
a set of principles to help guide them
through the often difficult decisions
when deciding on what treatment
directions are appropriate for a given
condition
first Do no harm or the principle of
non-malfeasance which basically means
don't do more harm than good so given an
existing problem it may be better to not
use a treatment option or even not do
anything rather than risking causing
more harm than good
the risk benefit or benefit risk ratio
is a way of attempting to weigh up the
risks of an action compared to the
benefits of that action based on the
understanding that it's necessary to
accept a certain level of risk in our
lives in order to achieve certain
benefits
the principle of double effects has it's
permissible to have a harmful side
effect of a treatment even resulting in
death so long as it's not intended and
occurs as a side effect of a beneficial
action
the principle of informed consent
requires that the patient must be
capable of making decisions for
themselves must have enough information
to make an informed choice and they must
be able to give their consent freely
the principle of autonomy means that a
patient has the ultimate decision-making
responsibility for their own treatment
and a medical practitioner cannot impose
treatment on a patient
the principle of confidentiality means
that professionals shouldn't share
personal details about someone without
their consent or unless it's absolutely
necessary
the principle of Justice Means all
patients deserve Advanced Health Care
delivery regardless of economic status
ethnicity sexual orientation gender Etc
the principle of proportionality means
that medical interventions and risks
should be proportionate to the possible
lives saved
and these are the main principles of
Medicine
when you've gone and snapped yourself
the first thing to do is phone an
ambulance and after a short wait you'll
be treated by the first line of medical
intervention paramedics
paramedics are trained to provide
emergency medical care wherever it's
needed they typically work as part of an
ambulance crew or a rapid response team
who respond to emergencies such as
accidents heart attacks Strokes or other
life-threatening conditions
they're trained to quickly figure out
what's wrong and provide medical
interventions such as providing cardiac
and respiratory support administering
medications or performing Advanced
Airway management they often have to
make quick decisions about the best
course of action
the next step is to get you to hospital
accident and emergency as fast as
possible AMD departments aim to provide
immediate Medical Care to patients
presenting with urgent or
life-threatening medical conditions from
accidents to heart attacks Strokes or
severe infections
they're staffed by a team of healthcare
professionals emergency physicians
nurses paramedics and other support
staff who are trained to respond quickly
to emergency situations and provide
immediate Medical Care
the department is typically open 24
hours a day seven days a week to provide
round-the-clock care to patients
they either patch you up and send you
away or refer you to other Medical
Specialties for further evaluation or
treatment or keep you in a critical or
intensive care unit known as an ICU
where the goal is to stabilize and
manage patients with severe medical
conditions or injuries this may include
monitoring Vital Signs administering
intravenous fluids and medications
providing respiratory support and
Performing procedures such as intubation
or mechanical ventilation
patients in critical care may have a
range of medical conditions including
sepsis heart failure respiratory failure
traumatic injuries neurological
emergencies amongst many other things
in certain situations you may need
surgery which involves the use of
invasive procedures to treat a wide
range of conditions and diseases from
ending broken bones minor procedures
such as removing moles and cysts to more
complex procedures such as organ
transplants and open heart surgery
surgeons use a variety of tools and
techniques such as scalpel forceps and
sutras to remove or repair damaged or
diseased tissue organs or bones although
increasingly surgery is performed by
Specialists using minimally invasive
techniques
the goal of surgery is to alleviate
symptoms prevent complications and
improve the patient's quality of life
surgeons work closely with
anesthesiologists who administer
anesthesia to numb parts of your body or
knock you out so you don't experience
pain during surgery
they also help patients manage pain
before during and after medical
procedures
the main goal of anesthesiology is to
ensure that the patient is as
comfortable and as safe as possible
during medical procedures they also
monitor the patient's Vital Signs and
adjust anesthesia doses as needed to
maintain the patient's level of
anesthesia and ensure their safety
but most of our interactions with the
field of medicine are a bit more
pedestrian
the most common way we interact with the
field of medicine is through our local
General Practitioners also known as
family doctors or primary care
physicians who serve as our first point
of contact for our ailments their role
is to offer routine checkups screenings
vaccinations and advice on General
well-being from diet and exercise to
mental health and keep track of their
patients overall health over time they
also help diagnose and treat a wide
range of acute and chronic illnesses
using diagnostic methods such as
physical examinations or ordering
laboratory tests they will also refer
patients to Specialists who work in the
many different areas of Medical Practice
which I'll be covering later
family doctors also write prescriptions
for drugs to say treat infections or for
birth control or to manage chronic
conditions like hypertension diabetes
depression and many others
you'll get your prescriptions from a
pharmacist who dispenses and offers
expertise on the safe use of
prescription medications and gives
advice on how to use them most
effectively so you get the best outcomes
Pharmacy is backed up by the basic
science of pharmacology I'm putting all
the science that supports medicine in
the blue sections
pharmacology is the study of drugs and
their effect on living organisms which
involves the study of their properties
actions uses and side effects
as well as their interaction with other
drugs and the mechanisms of action at
the molecular level cellular level or
the effect on the whole body
although I've put pharmacology as a
basic science in the blue section it's
an important field in both research and
medical practice and plays a critical
role in the development of new drugs and
treatments for a wide range of diseases
and conditions
an important sub-discipline of
pharmacology is toxicology which studies
the Hazardous effects of drugs poisons
and toxic substances like industrial
chemicals pesticides and pollutants on
the Body Research in toxicology has many
applications in public health
environmental science and Drug
development toxicologists play an
important role in identifying and
characterizing toxic substances
evaluating the risks Associated to
exposure to these substances and
developing strategies to mitigate those
risks
back to Medical Practice when you're
presenting to a medical practitioner
with something wrong it's their job to
figure out what's going on with you and
then determine the best course of action
figuring out what's wrong with you is by
no means an easy task so there are many
diagnostic methods available to doctors
to help them diagnose your ailments and
we'll look at these now
physical examination involves examining
the patient's body and Vital Signs
including their temperature blood
pressure and pulse as well as
examination of the Eyes Ears Nose Throat
skin and other parts of the body
if more investigation is warranted
laboratory tests give valuable
information by analyzing blood urine and
other bodily fluids to measure levels of
important biomolecules or detect the
presence of disease or infection
in cases where there's an unusual growth
a biopsy can be taken which involves
removing a small piece of tissue to
examine under a microscope to detect the
presence of cancer abnormal cells or
other diseases which is also known as a
histological examination
microbiological tests are used to
isolate and identify microorganisms such
as bacteria viruses fungi and parasites
immunological tests are used to measure
the immune system's response to
infection such as the measurement of
antibodies in the blood or the body's
response when introduced to certain
compounds
seeing inside the body is very helpful
for diagnosing conditions and there are
many Imaging tests like ultrasound
x-rays CT scans MRI and other Imaging
techniques which help to see your bones
internal organs and other structures to
help detect abnormalities or injuries
endoscopic procedures involve the use of
a flexible tube with a light and camera
at the end which is inserted into your
body at one end or the other to be able
to see your insides
some conditions like cystic fibrosis or
sickle cell anemia have a strong genetic
component and genetic testing analyzes a
person's DNA to identify inherited
genetic conditions
and psychological or psychiatric
evaluations look at a person's mental
health emotions and behavior to identify
any psychological or psychiatric
conditions
this gives you a good idea of the main
tools at the disposal of the healthcare
system to help figure out what's going
on and give doctors the information they
need to decide on the best course of
action
coming back to the areas of Medical
Practice Psychiatry deals with a
diagnosis treatment and prevention of
mental illnesses and emotional disorders
it's a diverse field that encompasses a
wide range of mental health conditions
such as anxiety depression
post-traumatic stress disorder addiction
bipolar disorder eating disorders and
schizophrenia amongst others
psychiatrists use a variety of
treatments to help individuals manage
their mental health conditions such as
counseling and therapy also known as
Psychotherapy medication and in severe
cases electroconvulsive therapy
it's worth noting that mental health
just like our physical well-being
affects us all and many people including
myself have benefited from therapy or
counseling simply when navigating Our
Lives
on a more mechanistic side neurology
looks at the diagnosis treatment and
management of disorders of the nervous
system including the brain spinal cord
and nerves
neurologists are experts in a wide range
of neurological conditions such as
headaches stroke epilepsy multiple
sclerosis Parkinson's disease and
Alzheimer's disease
treatment methods include medication
physical therapy and surgery to manage
neurological disorders
these branches of medicine are supported
by the basic research science of
Neuroscience which focuses on the
biology and physiology of the human
brain and nervous system this includes
its molecular and cellular mechanisms
neural circuits behavior and cognition
scientists use a variety of tools and
techniques to study the nervous system
which include brain Imaging
electrophysiology genetics and
behavioral testing and research in
Neuroscience has helped improve
treatments in neurology and psychiatry
this leads us to a really interesting
area of Medical Science the placebo
effect
this is where patients can be given a
treatment that doesn't actually do
anything physically but if you don't
tell them this and they think they're
getting a proper drug or surgery they
still experience improvements in their
symptoms or health condition just on the
basis that they believe it will work
the placebo effect has been well
documented in several areas especially
for pain management but we still don't
know exactly why it works although there
are many theories being tested involving
our natural endorphins or
neurotransmitters like dopamine
the reason I want to point out the
placebo effect is because in this map
I'm not covering treatments that fall
outside of evidence-based medicine like
acupuncture Homeopathy or Chiropractics
and many other so-called alternative
therapies because none of these work
because of how they say they work as far
as anyone can tell any positive effect
of these yet unproven interventions is
because of the placebo effect
in fact the only way to find out if
something actually works is to do a
clinical trial and there you don't have
to show that your new drug or
intervention performs better than
nothing you have to prove it performs
better than a placebo and if it does it
just becomes part of established
medicine
there's also a place the current crop of
Wellness influencers who are essentially
selling modern day snake oil which as
long as it doesn't have a negative
effect probably has a positive placebo
effect they just tend to be crazy
expensive
was even more interesting is that the
placebo effect still works even if you
know that you're taking a placebo which
is why I'm launching my new product
maximum strength Placebo by domain of
science if you need fast relief from
basically anything turn to maximum
strength Placebo it might be just a
placebo but it works trust me I'm a
doctor in fact this is the cheapest way
to get your magic pills because I'm not
even selling a bottle of pills I'm just
selling the label so you can make your
own Placebo at home take an old jar
stick on the label and fill it with your
favorite sugar pill bang Placebo the
ultimate in personalized medicine and
one you can use over and over again so
if you want to make your own Placebo go
to dosmaps.com where I'm also selling
the poster in fact I'm giving away a
free Placebo label with the first 500
map of medicine posters but please bear
in mind placebos could only improve a
limited amount of symptoms they can't
cure you of any proper medical issues
like a broken leg or cancer you know the
heavy stuff so if you're actually ill go
see a proper doctor
now the placebo effect is a truly
fascinating topic that I wanted to spend
way more time on but fortunately my
friend and cardiologist rohin has just
posted an epic video about the placebo
effect on his channel medlife crisis so
go check that out if you want to learn
more and I've learned loads about
medicine from his channel so that's a
great place to go after you've watched
this video
coming back to the areas of Medical
Practice one area we all interact with
is Dentistry which checks and manages
your teeth gums and mouth to treat
conditions like tooth decay gum disease
and oral cancer
they use a variety of treatment methods
such as fillings extractions root canals
and dental implants to manage oral
health and they work closely with other
Specialists such as orthodontists
periodontists and oral surgeons
for vision Ophthalmology treats
disorders of the eyes and visual system
as well as supplying us with corrective
lenses to help us see properly
ophthalmologists are experts in the
diagnosis and management of a wide range
of eye conditions such as cataracts
glaucoma amongst others and treatment
methods include medication laser therapy
and surgery to manage eye disorders
optometrists are experts in diagnosing
conditions such as nearsightedness
farsightedness and astigmatism and
prescribe corrective lenses on the basis
of vision tests
and the specialty known as ENT treats
conditions related to the ears nose
throat and other connected structures of
the head and neck an ENT doctor is
trained to treat a wide range of
conditions including ear infections
hearing loss sinusitis allergies
tonsillitis laryngeitis and Cancers of
the head and neck as well as being
Experts of Airway management
they're skilled with very delicate
surgical procedures in very small or
cramped anatomical regions
getting regular checkups from your
doctor is a form of preventative
medicine which is the medical specialty
that focuses on promoting health and
preventing disease to try and keep
people healthy rather than just treating
them when they become ill to Simply
avoid a lot of humans suffering from
happening in the first place
strategies include vaccinations Health
screenings and promoting a healthy
lifestyle to try and reduce the risk of
disease or injury and catching chronic
conditions early when they're more
manageable
Immunology is the study of the immune
system how it works and how it defends
the body against infections and diseases
it also includes cancer Immunology which
looks at the body's innate ability to
prevent or eliminate cancer cells called
immunosurveillance as well as new
treatments like genetically engineered
car T cells used to Target certain forms
of cancer
Immunology also studies disorders of the
immune system such as allergies and
autoimmunity
immunologists use a variety of treatment
methods such as medication immunotherapy
and bone marrow or stem cell
transplantation to manage immune
disorders
public health is a branch of medicine
that focuses on the Improvement of the
health of communities and populations
disease prevention promoting Healthy
Lifestyles development of Healthcare
systems and policies and improving the
health of the population through
education Public Health Works to
identify and address the root causes of
health problems rather than just
treating individual patients Public
Health also encompasses emergency
preparedness and response in activities
like vaccination campaigns and outbreak
investigations so crosses over with
epidemiology biostatistics and social
and Behavioral Sciences
this is related to nutrition science
which is the study of how the food we
eat affects our health
put nutrition sites in this section for
basic medical Sciences is it's the study
of the nutrients in food and how our
body uses them
but there's also a practical side
dietetics where dietitians apply
nutrition science to help with
conditions like allergies diabetes
cardiovascular diseases and weight and
eating disorders amongst others or help
athletes perform at their best
another important element of Public
Health is epidemiology which studies how
health problems spread in populations or
tracking which populations have them
something we're all very familiar with
since the covid-19 pandemic
epidemiologists use statistical studies
and scientific methods to investigate
the origins and spread of diseases or
other health events in whole populations
and not just in humans
they try to identify the risk factors
for a disease and work out how effective
different treatment plans will be as
well as measuring the impact of Health
policies on the population
which brings us to infectious disease
which deals with the diagnosis treatment
and prevention of infections caused by
microorganisms such as bacteria viruses
fungi and parasites
infectious disease Physicians are
experts in identifying and managing
infections as well as interpreting
laboratory results and identifying
potential outbreaks
there are many ways infectious diseases
can spread contact with infected animals
or people contaminated food or water or
through bites from infected insects or
even in healthcare settings through
contaminated surfaces or medical
equipment which is why hygiene measures
are so important also antibiotic
resistance is one of the leading causes
of death globally as I found out in my
map of Doom which is why the appropriate
use of antibiotics to treat bacterial
infections is vitally important
infectious disease Physicians work
closely with microbiologists who study
microorganisms including viruses
bacteria fungi protozoa and other
microscopic organisms like parasites
microbiology applies to many different
fields like biotechnology or food
production but in the medical setting
microbiologists are also experts in
antimicrobial medication like antibiotic
or antifungal medication so although
I've put microbiology in the basic
Sciences it has a clinical role as well
closely related to these sections is
pathology which studies the changes in
the body that happen because of a
disease like changes in cells their
shape or size or how they function or
changes in tissues or organs
Pathologists use this information to
help diagnose and classify diseases and
also understand what caused the disease
and how it progresses and resolves
there are two main branches of pathology
an atomic pathology which looks at
tissues and organs and Clinical
Pathology which looks at body fluids
like blood and urine
pathology is also used in forensic
medicine to determine the cause of death
okay this has been a lot of information
so let's just take a minute's break
while I tell you about the sponsor of
this video
brilliant.org an educational app and
website where I like to spend my spare
moments of downtime improving my
knowledge in Science and Mathematics
which makes me feel better about myself
compared to using all them addictive
social media apps it's got thousands of
lessons from maths and physics to
computer science and AI which is what
I'm currently learning about I love the
freedom of learning at my own pace in my
own time in an environment where it's
okay to make mistakes and get things
wrong which is what education should be
like and these little bits of effort end
up building up to some real valuable
understanding
and I'm really into brilliant
visualization similar to my own approach
to education which I find really helps
get my head around abstract Concepts
anyway if you're interested please go to
brilliant.org Dos or just click on the
link in the description below which lets
them know that you've come from here and
this helps me out a bit too they're
offering a free 30-day trial on all of
their content and if you decide to carry
on the first 200 to sign up through my
link will get a 20 discount off an
annual premium subscription
okay thanks for listening now back to
the map of Medicine
one kind of surgery worth highlighting
is plastic surgery which people often
think of as cosmetic surgery but there's
important clinical uses where it's used
to manage and repair conditions like
Burns congenital defects like clef
pallets traumatic injuries or repairs
from cancer treatment
plastic surgeons use a variety of
techniques like skin grafts tissue
expansion or reconstruction
next is Dermatology which treats
conditions of the skin like eczema acne
psoriasis and skin cancer as well as
disorders involving our hair and nails
dermatologists play a vital role in the
early detection and management of skin
cancer which is one of the most common
and potentially deadly types of cancer
treatment methods include cryotherapy
laser therapy as well as medication and
surgery
in fact in all the following areas when
I'm describing treatment methods
everything uses medication and surgery
so rather than repeating myself over and
over again from now on you can assume
medication and surgery are always
treatment options and so I'll just be
mentioning specific treatment methods
which apply to each area
now we're getting into the realm of
internal medicine which is an umbrella
term containing many specialisms in
medicine which I'll be covering here
it's worth mentioning that there are
many different ways to order the field
of medicine in this map I've used the
systems based approach which is the most
common and it lends itself to this kind
of compartmentalization
so now on to oncology which deals with
the diagnosis treatment and prevention
of cancer it's a multi-disciplinary
field which encompasses a wide range of
cancer types such as lung cancer breast
cancer prostate cancer colorectal cancer
and blood cancers amongst others
oncologists are involved in all aspects
of Cancer Care from screening and
diagnosis to treatment follow-up care
and palliative care and treatment
includes a variety of methods such as
radiation therapy chemotherapy
immunotherapy and targeted therapy which
treats cancer by targeting proteins that
control how cancer cells grow divide and
spread
this brings us to Radiology which
harnesses Imaging techniques such as
x-ray computed tomography or CT scans
MRI or magnetic resonance imaging
ultrasound and nuclear medicine to
diagnose and treat a wide range of
medical conditions
Radiologists are also experts in the
interpretation of medical images and
also play an important role in guiding
and monitoring the progress of treatment
for medical conditions such as cancer
and other diseases
close to Radiology is the basic science
of radiobiology which studies the effect
of ionizing radiation on living
organisms
ionizing radiation like x-rays or gamma
radiation can cause damage to DNA which
can lead to mutations or cell death
at the cellular level radiation can
affect cell function Division and
survival
at the whole body level radiation
exposure can cause acute effects such as
radiation sickness or chronic effects
such as an increased risk of cancer or
other diseases
on the other hand radiation can also be
harnessed in radiation therapy which is
a common treatment for cancer so the
understanding of radiobiology can help
mitigate against and treat illnesses
less harmful radiation due to its lower
energy is the realm of photobiology
which looks at the interactions between
non-ionizing radiation in living
organisms
photobiology involves the study of how
organisms from bacteria to humans
interact with light and how these
interactions can affect their physiology
metabolism and behavior
this includes the effects of light on
photosynthesis Vision circadian rhythms
and vitamin D synthesis amongst others
clinical examples include phototherapy
or newborns to help treat jaundice or
photodynamic therapy which uses
photosensitizing agents and light to
kill cancer cells
here I'd like to take a little detour to
the basic science of medical physics
which is the study of the principles of
physics as applied to medicine and is
where all of the Imaging techniques like
x-rays CT and MRI scans and ultrasound
were developed
but medical physics is also involved in
treatments as well as Imaging for
example radiation therapy or proton beam
therapy which are used to treat cancer
in General Medical physics plays an
important role in developing new
technologies and techniques for use in
medicine
still in the realm of physics but
distinct from medical physics is
biophysics which focuses on the physical
and mechanical properties of biological
systems including cells tissues and
organisms
it seeks to understand the fundamental
physical and chemical mechanisms that
underlie biological processes such as
the structure and function of
biomolecules such as proteins and
nucleic acids in molecular biophysics
or in cellular biophysics which focuses
on the study of the physical properties
of cells and their interactions with
their environment
or systems biophysics which focuses on
the study of the physical and mechanical
properties of biological systems at the
level of whole organisms
next we have biochemistry which focuses
on the chemical processes in chemical
substances that occur within living
organisms
it involves the study of the chemical
structure and function of biological
molecules such as proteins nucleic acids
carbohydrates and lipids and the
biochemical reactions and Pathways that
are involved in the regulation of these
molecules
biochemistry plays a crucial role in
understanding the mechanisms of disease
for example the biochemical Pathways
involved in cancer or say diabetes in
order to develop new diagnostic tools or
therapeutic interventions
also the development of new drugs often
involves studying the structure of
proteins to identify new drug targets
back to the areas of medical practice we
come to Cardiology which deals with the
conditions of the heart and diagnosis of
a wide range of cardiovascular problems
such as coronary artery disease heart
failure arrhythmias valvular heart
disease and hypertension
cardiologists use a variety of
diagnostic tools such as
electrocardiograms ECG
echocardiograms and angiograms to
evaluate and diagnose cardiovascular
disorders
they also use a variety of treatment
methods such as angioplasty stenting
heart surgery and endovascular treatment
to manage cardiovascular disorders
then we come to Nephrology which deals
with a diagnosis and management of a
wide range of kidney related conditions
such as chronic kidney disease acute
kidney injury kidney stones
glomerulonephritis and hypertension
the kidney is a complex organ that
performs many vital functions such as
filtering waste products from the blood
generating red blood cells regulating
electrolyte balance and regulating blood
pressure and to counteract kidney
conditions nephrologists use treatment
methods such as dialysis and kidney
transplantation in the case of kidney
failure
next we have hematology which looks at
our blood and disorders of blood cells
or the places they're produced like bone
marrow or the lymphatic system
examples of blood disorders are anemia
Leukemia Lymphoma and bleeding disorders
like hemophilia
the diagnostic tools hematologists use
include blood tests bone marrow biopsies
and imaging studies and treatment
methods include chemotherapy radiation
therapy bone marrow or stem cell
transplantation and immune or cell-based
therapies depending on the disorder
being treated
now onto the lungs and respiratory
system with respiratory medicine or
pulmonology
respiratory conditions include things
like asthma chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease lung cancer and
Sarcoidosis and pulmonologists use
diagnostic tools such as x-rays CT scans
lung function tests and bronchoscopy to
evaluate and diagnose respiratory
disorders
treatment includes oxygen therapy which
can help manage respiratory disorders
and medication that's applied by
inhalation
now to our guts with gastroenterology
which deals with disorders of the
digestive system which includes the
esophagus stomach small and large
intestines rectum as well as the liver
gallbladder and pancreas
examples of digestive disorders are
peptic ulcer disease inflammatory bowel
disease celiac disease and liver disease
and gastroenterologists use diagnostic
tools such as endoscopy colonoscopy and
imaging studies to see what's going on
with treatments commonly involving
endoscopic procedures
Urology deals with the urinary tract and
the male reproductive system diagnosing
and treating conditions such as urinary
tract infections prostate problems
kidney stones and male infertility
urologists use diagnostic tools
including urine tests blood tests
Imaging studies and biopsies to evaluate
and diagnose Urologic conditions and
endoscopic procedures are a common
method used in treatment
the study of hormones and their effect
throughout the body is covered by the
field of endocrinology
the endocrine system is made up of
glands that produce and secrete hormones
which are chemical Messengers that
regulate various bodily functions such
as metabolism growth and development and
reproduction examples of disorders of
the endocrine system include diabetes
thyroid disorders osteoporosis and
hormonal imbalances
endocrinologists use blood tests Imaging
studies and hormone level measurements
to evaluate endocrine disorders and
treatment can include hormone
replacement therapy
Gynecology and obstetrics or OB GYN is a
specialty that focuses on the care of
women's reproductive health and is
focused on pregnancy childbirth and the
postpartum period and is closely related
to Reproductive Medicine in techniques
like IVF
Gynecology deals with the diagnosis and
treatment of conditions of the female
reproductive system an OB GYN provides
prenatal care delivers babies and
manages complications of pregnancy they
also perform gynecological exams Pap
tests and screenings for sexually
transmitted infections
they may also provide contraceptive
counseling and diagnose and treat
conditions such as fibroids
endometriosis and cancer of the
reproductive system
we also have Rheumatology which focuses
on disorders of the joints muscles and
Bones as well as other connective tissue
disorders such as lupus rheumatoid
arthritis and scleroderma
rheumatologists are experts in the
diagnosis and management of a wide range
of rheumatic conditions which are often
lifelong conditions which can be
debilitating and include chronic pain
diagnostic tools include physical
examination Imaging studies and
laboratory tests and physical therapy is
a common treatment method
Rheumatology also shares a loss of
ground with Immunology as many diseases
it's concerned with are disorders of the
immune system
while we're in the realm of internal
medicine this is a good time to talk
about anatomy and physiology which
together form the foundation of the
biological sciences and are essential to
understanding the workings of the human
body
Anatomy is the study of the physical
structure of organisms and so is
relevant to all the areas of internal
medicine
Anatomy breaks down into several
sub-disciplines
gross anatomy also known as macroscopic
Anatomy studies the structure of the
body without the use of a microscope so
organs tissues and other body structures
and typically involves the dissection of
cadavers or the use of models and other
Educational Tools to study the anatomy
of the body
it's often studied by medical and
Healthcare students to provide a
foundation for understanding the
structure and function of the human body
histology is the part of anatomy that
studies the microscopic structure and
function of biological tissues and in
medical practice histology is used to
identify the presence of disease in
tissues obtained from biopsies or
surgical specimens
histology involves the preparation of
tissue samples which are then stained
with various dyes to highlight different
structures and cellular components
these samples are then examined under a
microscope to identify any abnormalities
or signs of disease which can include
cancer infectious diseases autoimmune
disorders in genetic disorders
it can also be used to monitor the
progress of a disease and the
effectiveness of treatment
in basic Medical Science advances in
histology have led to better
understanding of the mechanisms of
disease which has helped develop new
treatments for many diseases
cytology is the part of anatomy that
focuses on the study of cells including
their structure function and behavior in
medical practice cytology is commonly
used in diagnostic medicine to identify
abnormal cells that may indicate the
presence of cancer or other diseases
this is typically done by analyzing
cells obtained from various parts of the
body such as the cervix breast or lungs
using a technique called a cytologic
smear or a cytologic brush
these cells are then examined under a
microscope to look for any abnormalities
or signs of disease
during treatment cytology can also be
used to assess the response of tumors to
chemotherapy or radiation therapy in
basic medical research advances in
cytology have led to better
understanding of Cell Biology which has
helped contribute to the development of
new treatments for a wide range of
diseases
the final section within Anatomy is
embryology which studies the development
of embryos and fetuses from
fertilization to birth and involves the
study of the physical genetic and
biochemical processes that underlie the
formation and growth of an organism from
a single fertilized egg cell
topics include fertilization cell
division and differentiation organ
formation and growth and development
embryology is important in both medical
practice and research as it provides a
foundation for understanding the causes
of birth defects genetic disorders and
other developmental abnormalities and so
understanding the mechanisms that
underlie how the body develops informs
how we treat these conditions
next to Anatomy the other Foundation of
Medical Science is physiology which
focuses on how living organisms function
compared to Anatomy which focuses on
their structure
physiology involves the study of the
physical chemical and biochemical
processes that underlie the normal
functioning of living organisms at many
different levels on the level of cells
tissues organs or whole systems
it also looks at the mechanisms that
lead to disease and dysfunction
physiology is an important field in both
medical practice and research it
provides a foundation for understanding
the mechanisms of disease and the
development of new treatments as well as
the effects of drugs and other
interventions on the body
it's also crucial for understanding the
normal functioning of the body and the
ways in which it adapts to changing
environments or stresses
strongly related to these foundations of
biology is the fundamental science of
genetics which studies genes heredity
and genetic variation in living
organisms
it's a broad field that encompasses many
different subfields including molecular
genetics evolutionary genetics
population genetics and medical genetics
genes are units of heredity that are
responsible for passing traits from one
generation to the next so in medicine
genetic testing can be used to diagnose
genetic disorders or identify the risk
of developing certain diseases
clinical genetics is a huge success
story in medicine where sequencing a
human genome used to take over a decade
and cost many billions of dollars it can
now be done for a couple of hundred
dollars in a few days due to advances in
biotechnology and bioinformatics
closely related to genetics is molecular
biology which studies the molecular
basis of biological activity such as the
structure and function of biomolecules
like nucleic acids and proteins
it looks at the molecular mechanisms
that regulate the expression of genetic
information and the processes of
replication transcription and
translation of DNA
molecular biology helps us understand
the genetic and biochemical processes
that underlie life and has led to the
development of many new technologies and
techniques from genetic engineering to
drug Discovery and disease diagnosis and
treatment
coming back to the areas of medical
practice again there are Specialties
that focus on specific stages of Our
Lives
Pediatrics focuses on the medical care
of infants children and adolescents from
birth to Young adulthood
pediatricians provide care to children
with chronic conditions such as asthma
diabetes and sickle cell anemia and
provide routine checkups immunizations
and developmental assessments on
youngsters
pediatricians also provide guidance and
support to parents and caregivers
helping them to understand and meet the
needs of their children
also pediatricians are trained to work
well with kids and adapt their approach
and communication to the age and
development of the child
for the later stages of Our Lives we
have geriatrics which focuses on older
adults and the diagnosis and management
of a wide range of health conditions
that are more common in this population
such as arthritis heart disease stroke
and dementia
geriatricians are trained to understand
the challenges that older adults face
such as the management of complex
chronic conditions or age-related
Frailty and disability and end-of-life
care
but regardless of your age if you have a
medical condition you'll receive
treatment from nurses who work in a
variety of settings such as hospitals
clinics long-term care facilities and
patients homes
they have a wide range of
responsibilities to help people maintain
Optimal Health or recover quality of
life these include administering
medications performing physical exams
monitoring Vital Signs and collecting
patient information
they also play an important role in
patient education helping patients
understand and manage their conditions
nurses also work closely with doctors
and other Healthcare professionals to
develop and Implement treatment plans
and they also serve as advocates for
their patients
now we get to physical medicine and
rehabilitation or PMR which aims to
improve the function Independence and
quality of life for individuals with
impairments disabilities or pain from a
wide range of conditions these can
include spinal cord injury stroke
amputation traumatic brain injury
chronic pain or other musculoskeletal
neurological or cardiovascular
conditions
this is closely related to physiotherapy
as physiatrists and physiotherapists
treat similar conditions but their
duties and responsibilities are
different in pmnr physiatrists perform
invasive procedures such as injections
and EMG therapy while physiotherapists
focus more on body movement through
methods such as exercise manual therapy
and education aiming to help patients
recover from things like surgery or
injury or manage chronic conditions such
as arthritis back pain and improve
overall physical fitness strength
flexibility and balance
this brings us to Orthopedics which
focuses on the diagnosis treatment and
management of disorders of the
musculoskeletal system which includes
bones joints muscles tendons ligaments
and nerves
and looks at conditions such as
fractures dislocations arthritis Spinal
Disorders and sports injuries
orthopedic surgeons use x-rays MRI and
CT scans to evaluate problems and
treatments can involve surgery
medication and physical therapy
here's a good place to talk about the
basic science of biomechanics which
focuses on the study of the mechanical
principles that govern the movement and
structure of living organisms
it involves the application of
principles from physics engineering and
Mathematics to the study of biological
systems from the level of individual
cells to the movement of whole organisms
biomechanics encompasses many subfields
including kinematics which studies the
motion of objects without considering
the forces that cause the motion
kinetics which studies the forces that
cause motion and deformation which
studies the response of biological
tissues to external forces
biomechanics plays an important role in
the development of Prosthetics and other
devices that assist people with Mobility
impairments
is also used in the study of sports
injuries and the development of sports
equipment as well as in the design of
medical implants and surgical procedures
and at the end of the areas of medical
practice we come to palliative medicine
which specializes in end-of-life care
for people living with serious illnesses
such as heart failure cancer dementia
Parkinson's disease and many others
creative care aims to help with symptoms
and help patients understand their
choices for medical treatment as well as
supporting a person's quality of life
for them and their family for the time
they have left
those are all the areas of medical
practice but in the last section of the
video I want to focus on how we know
that a drug or treatment will actually
work it's all about data
first we have the field of
bioinformatics which combines computer
science mathematics statistics and
biology to analyze and interpret
biological data particularly large-scale
data generated by high throughput
Technologies like genome sequencing
projects as well as other molecular
biology experiments
it's got many applications in
biomedicine such as identifying
disease-causing mutations or predicting
drug efficacy and side effects and also
designing personalized treatments
bioinformatics has also contributed to
the development of many publicly
available databases which are essential
resources for researchers in many fields
then we have the field of biostatistics
which is the application of statistical
methods to biological medical and public
health research
it involves the design analysis and
interpretation of data generated by
experiments or clinical trials or
observational studies and other types of
research
and it's used in many areas including
epidemiology genetics clinical research
and Public Health
the field of biostatistics has many
applications such as identifying risk
factors for a disease or assessing the
impact of Public Health interventions
and developing predictive models to help
with diagnosis and treatment of medical
conditions
but arguably the most important
application of biostatistics is
evaluating the effectiveness of new
Medical Treatments through clinical
trials essentially applying the
principles of science to medicine this
is the only way we can move forwards
with new treatments and be sure they
actually work work better than a placebo
as I mentioned there are many different
kinds of clinical trials so let's look
at them in this final section
phase one trials are the first type of
Trials to test a new drug or treatment
in humans they're typically conducted on
a small number of healthy volunteers and
are used to find the best dose of
treatment find out what the side effects
are and what happens to the treatment in
the body
phase two trials are conducted on a
larger group of patients and are used to
evaluate how well the treatment works
find the best dose of treatment and find
out more about the side effects
phase 3 trials are conducted on large
groups of patients and are used to
confirm the effectiveness of the drug or
treatment and compare it to the standard
treatment or to a placebo
phase 4 trials are conducted after the
drug or treatment has been approved by
the regulatory authorities and are used
to find out about the long-term benefits
and side effects
a randomized control trial is a type of
trial in which patients are randomly
assigned to receive either the
experimental treatment or a standard
treatment or a placebo this type of
trial is considered the gold standard
for evaluating the effectiveness of a
treatment
adaptive trials are used to adapt the
trial design in response to the data
that are collected during the trial it
allows doctors to optimize the trial
design and increase the efficiency and
power of the trial
Interventional trials involve a change
in the care that a patient receives and
are used to evaluate the effectiveness
of the treatment or procedure
exploratory trials are used to gather
preliminary data on a new drug or
treatment typically in a small number of
patients they're used to determine
whether further research is warranted or
not
observational trials are used to gather
information about a particular disease
or condition in a population without
manipulating any of the variables
they're usually used to identify risk
factors or potential causes of a disease
in metra-analyzes also known as
systematic reviews combine the results
of multiple scientific studies that are
looking at the same question
and they use approaches from statistics
to combine all of the results to produce
an overall summary of an area of
research
meta-analytic results considered the
most trustworthy source of evidence in
medicine
so that's the map of medicine I hope
this map has helped you get your head
around this large and fascinating
subject thank you so much for watching
and keeping up with my channel and I'll
see you in the next map video